last night President Trump tweeted a
reminder to Iran not to mess with us
it was in all caps showing the world
that he's not afraid to go all caps
what's next if you listen to the media
it has to be war fact is trump was just
trump was just responding to the iranian
president who warned us about a mother
of all wars remember the last guy who
said that yet predictably the media
freaks out for getting that whole North
Korea thing which followed this same
pattern so forgive me if unlike CNN I'm
not pulling my hair out so I'll take a
war of words over a war of Worlds now
the media claims this tweets a
distraction from last week's summit yet
how did that summit hurt Trump for all
the media shaming is at forty five
percent approval that's as high as so
far and we're happier with the country's
direction than any time in the last
eight years this confuses the media as
they keep saying that Trump is the worst
thing to ever happen since the view may
be because they've cried wolf so many
times even Blitzer ignores it it's the
gulf between what the media wants to
matter and what actually matters
according to Gallup in terms of
importance to voters the Russia
collusion story rated so small it could
barely be measured it's under 1% to
Americans Jesse's new haircut mattered
more and it's not even a good haircut
anyway now the media will say that the
tweet means we're all doomed not really
it's the mullahs who should be nervous
meanwhile on CNN it's part 200 of the
collusion follies on MSNBC a prime time
end of the world special on ABC deep
political analysis with joy
NBC Lester Holt and on CBS some guy my
advice keep it here all right Dana we're
seeing an evolution in tweeting all caps
thumbs up or thumbs down didn't start
his all caps with the crescendo yes all
caps like he really means it yes one
thing I thought was I thought back to is
in April of 2009 I think is when the
Green Revolution happened in Iran that's
when the people rose up yeah they wanted
help from the United States they did not
get it
and
you know here we are in 2018 not that
help could have definitely changed
things but they needed more help than
they deserve but I remember at the time
that was really started by Twitter right
and people on the ground we're doing and
the mullahs had no idea what Twitter was
and boy have things changed because now
they're actually having tweet wars yeah
the president which actually can
actually build friendships cuz we
started out that way that's exactly how
it starts remember you me yes the
Twitter war really and then I want it
I'm happy to have the United States and
the world talk about Iran for a week
yeah because we've talked about it
Russia a ton we've talked about North
Korea a ton meanwhile Iran does a lot of
bad things all around the world and I
think that their time to call him out on
it
I think the other reason they're doing
this is that the snapback sanctions
happen in two weeks
and so the mullahs are about to feel the
squeeze the mullahs are worried all
right why this is this a deja tweet you
know this is exactly how he began with
the fire in fury with North Korea and
the next thing you know Kim jong-un is
his best pal yeah that's still
apparently he's very irritated that
nothing's come of that yes of those
talks with Kim Jong right but I will say
this to me I'm still struck by the idea
he is still among even though his
numbers bumped up in The Wall Street
Journal poll to 45 percent is yes that's
still among the lowest of all modern
presidents in terms of approval and I
think that when we think about Helsinki
and Putin it's because the Republican
base is like a cult with Donald Trump
they just don't budge they don't care it
doesn't matter to them I was struck by
though by the whole media CICU and
Dana's saying oh it's good we need to
talk about Iran they're doing this and I
think to myself I think Donald Trump is
out foxing everybody because what he's
doing is saying let's talk about NFL
players we're talking about Iran let's
talk about let's talk about Iran let's
talk about the Federal Reserve raising
interest rates let's talk about the the
FBI ranked into Carlin's office let's
talk about tariffs on China let's talk
about anybody nobody talks about that he
talks about that anyway he I don't think
he cares and but I also don't think he
thinks Helsinki was that big of a deal
like most of America Jesse most of
America is more interested with your
strange haircut you know my mother told
me to stop talking about my hair
or that insult Greg I will say this
though the same Democrats upset with
Donald Trump for tweeting all in caps
sent Iran billions all in cash the cats
it's like was a Teddy Roosevelt speak
softly carry a big stick
he speaks loudly and carries a big stick
and that's fine I think what he's trying
to do is say we're gonna respond when
you're gonna talk trash he's an ultimate
trash talker and Iran is Putin's
puppet and he's rhetorically blasting
Iran and he's actually bombing their
other puppets Syria so how is he in
cahoots with the Russians such a great
makes no sense ya know so Joe Katie this
has to do with Russia in a way I would
add but Syria it has to do with the
Middle East as a whole it has to do with
foreign policy of Afghanistan and
Afghanistan you know there is now this
restructuring going on of the Middle
East when it comes to everybody
essentially becoming allies and a little
bit of a way to go against Iran and when
you look at the you know what is being
reported as one just tried to distract
back to and all these other topics that
we're not discussing right now there are
very serious things going on in Iran and
although we've been focused on other
topics on the surface level with the
media in the United States there are
very serious consequences to what could
happen there inflation is a hundred and
fifty nine percent in that country a
third of the Iranian youth are
unemployed and the Iranian regime now is
facing the consequences of using all of
the money they've been getting from the
United States from the Europeans and
they're spending it on terrorism and the
people there have been protesting for
years now because they know that anyway
look at the speech the secretary Pompeo
gave at the Reagan Library it is very
clear that they are not saying we want
regime change but based on the language
of standing with the people talking
about maybe putting more sanctions on
threatening back when Iran by the way
threatens us first and dealing with the
problem that quite frankly President
Obama did not handle very well I think
the venue of the speech was important to
the Reagan Library I mean yours will be
as impactful I think I change the world
by the way you know I have to point out
that the Iranian guy also said the
what's possible is the mother of all
do you think there was I think that
they're absolutely believe that
President Trump will say why don't we
just meet yeah okay and then imagine
when when the Republicans lost their
minds was Obama's like maybe I should
talk to them like Denis try to meet him
before already didn't I think there's
letters yeah a lot of letters that said
for me there's um I want to play us
sound on tape from a network see what's
at CNN yeah they are they're still
around they're hanging by a thread
though it's about they're there wagging
the dog scenario that this is actually a
distraction roll it please I don't want
to go full wag the dog but I mean we
know that the president's strategy I
mean the president's strategy he's
employed it over and over we would be
foolish not to absorb it and recognize
it he'd when he's embarrassed as he was
last week he always looks because he was
[Laughter]
last week if you really want to do this
it's also rich talking about wagging the
dog with Democrats I think it was Bill
Clinton who bombed an aspirin factory
during the Lewinsky testimony so I think
they know a little bit about wagging the
dog so in other words you're not denying
that that's exactly what he's doing know
if he had wag that it would have been a
week ago I actually think that it all is
in the lead up to these sanctions that
are going to go back into place on
August 6 which is only like 12 days away
I think that it's the lead-up to that so
that people aren't surprised by when the
president says we're snapping back these
things the big snap back to my mind is
when he says on you know he was walking
back last at the end of last week oh you
know I didn't mean to say that the
Russians weren't responsible
interference Sunday night he says this
whole thing is a hoax the actual what
he's saying when he says hoax
Sarah sander said today what he means is
that the the accusation of collusion so
you so would or wouldn't you know what I
mean it's always like something but he
just keeps shifting it and for some
reason it satisfies the GOP depends what
the meaning of is
oh yeah House and the Senate they're so
afraid of the Republicans who march and
lockstep to trump that they are biting
their tongues but then you see people on
Russia oh they do big it's nothing
compared to the cult of Obama let's face
it for eight years the media did nothing
but but Obama's bidding so please I work
at Fox News I know we weren't doing
Obama's been look going back to Dana's
point which is the overall construct of
how we're moving forward on Iran we went
toward the Iran deal President Trump got
rid of it there are going to be
consequences moving forward how the
administration deals with the regime and
they are obviously looking at the idea
of Iran not being able to sustain
economically any kind of sanctions or
further pressure the United States puts
on them because it will lead to regime
change with the which the u.s. is not
officially pushing for but based on the
things that have been said the pressure
that's been put on Pompeo calling out
the leaders by name and saying that
they're hypocritical holy men and
tweeting and farsi to the activists on
the ground there you know this is an
overall strategy for the administration
it's not just a distraction from russia
because we've been dealing with this
even before Trump became president on
the campaign trip is anybody like the
like the mullahs Oh in Iran I mean the
people I mean out how much sway do they
have with the military right they get
the goodies right and if you're yeah
it's just a typical dictatorial regime I
think the other thing that we forget is
that in Afghanistan and in Iraq in
particular
Iraq is actually doing much better from
a long governance standpoint but Iran is
prob as causing additional problems and
they're moving into Afghanistan and I
think you forget though that there's a
counter to the US sanctions I think US
sanctions KT are gonna have some pain
cause some pain for the Iranians but
don't forget the other parties in what
was a six-party agreement on the Iranian
deal are still in it still doing it and
they're cropping up terrorists more
terrorism around the world arguing that
point with you I would agree that they
are terrorists but I would say this that
are you any money why the United States
acting unilaterally we are becoming more
isolated and weaker on the world stage
we should have our allies with us going
against the arraign
we shouldn't be separated out so that we
can be identified by the mullahs as just
the big bad Americans who think they're
gonna run the world okay so do you think
the president's tweet was strong or weak
I think it was a distraction from all
his trouble the width the width of
Russians and Helsinki no wait we want to
we want to pull back yet we want to run
the world oh no it was that possible
because we talked it's leading from
behind that's what he's trying to do if
he was that subtle I would tip my cap to
you'll be tipping your cap